um
[Música]
[Aplausos]
negócio que coisa assim
apaixonado ninguém cuidou tão bem assim
de mim ficar do meu lado a gente que
brinca e coisa e tal eu não penso mais
nada para sempre sorrindo a felicidade
mas é melhor que não
eu quero você na minha vida se eu souber
que você sair para ver as flores mais
bonitas cidades aqui em casa agora não
sai da minha vida eu sei que é difícil
querida eu andar tão para baixo
encontrar uma saída a minha entrega é
melhor
te contei todas as minhas feridas
lado ela é particular Mas eu sou só uma
parte e você saiu né Poderia Decolar da
sua filha de jato particular filho que
estiver de outra vida pedir muito charme
dinheiro eu peço que eu pagar mais caro
que as férias mais tarde eu posso pagar
está comportando me dando carinho
mandando que a gente segue planejando
você já me deu outra vez casa
E aí
Bom
[Música]
descanso
para você na minha vida tudo bem com
você saída e as flores mais bonitas da
Dita aqui em casa vou não sair da minha
vida eu sei que é difícil querida eu
ando tão pra baixo
encontrar uma saída
para
saber quem tem saída
aqui em casa da minha vida que a gente
querida pronta pra baixo encontrar saída
[Música]
eu passo aí